what dude you got coffee from the play
singing yeah I got coffee from I don't
know yeah I got coffee from fun um oh
because it's [ __ ] rock Monday brother
yeah and and you don't give me a cough
yeah dude why now haters give me coffee
daddy always gets me I don't know why I
was loving it I didn't like your
attitude
silently this more no reason I was like
I don't think he deserves coffee today
oh my has his own coffee no I was good I
wait to go cross street Tommy and I go
man I should have got anyone I just
didn't I was like I don't know if he
appreciates know I loved it I know it's
so far and what I don't like is how you
pretend you discovered it cuz me and
Tony Jefferies have been going there for
seven years
hey hold on I did discover it no bro
Tony Jefferies did he did yeah when I
first met her he took me there I was
like [ __ ] it's got a real coffee joint
you know MA he's like mate I'm telling
you mate telling me every time I see him
I go like this I go remember when we
used to be friends me up dude I haven't
spoke to him in I don't know six months
yeah I text him yesterday it's exactly
alright hey Marilyn we used to be
friends
mm-hmm started laughing yep he's got
three kids all eating three daughters
they couldn't look more like him they
all didn't it couldn't be more blonde
Tony you know this um and they're sure
ray who's I think 64 and couldn't look
better either now now you know I got
Glen my trainer Glenna so I've just been
doing peloton like a madman right yeah
I'll called got him long and so for to
hunt when I'm like I gotta get out of my
comfort zone so I got Glen come to the
crib now today's up today tomorrow's our
first day work it out with Glen gonna
start pushing the hard Brian doesn't
[ __ ] around you you're a big fan of Glen
Glen's a beast yeah he's a beast cuz I
don't need the bar I don't need like the
technology was there when Sugar Ray's X
I woulda got another and moved around so
fun to see I hate sure do you want to
move around Tony's always posting these
fight things huh how to fight a southpaw
um was always glad because I don't need
all the technical [ __ ] I don't anything
you let me keep your hands no I just
give me the workout dude I did that way
too long yeah you've had pictures over
you bad actors come up to you and say
keep your hand in not out
that's the better your hey hey you
hey hey now hey get back on set shut
your [ __ ] mouth back on set hey now
later doctor on set that's right that's
right
you bet don't don't give me any advice I
do I that's the one thing about moving
on Cinemark I do the one thing I miss
most is uh moving down that Beach I said
it out a little pipe down about
Manhattan the bobbies on this Manhattan
be it's a bubble and I like it you won't
how about this morning we're getting
coffee and we bake too many plans and
move everything he sends me a house
yesterday yeah that's dope I'd be down I
know we can move the studio there let's
the blah blah blah and then right now we
just started laughing like do or [ __ ]
crazy I know me and your guesthouse
imagine that in my robe no no no too
much well too much give my robe we get
you apartment I I was I was shacking up
with our boy frank grillo who has a nice
little place down in Venice and in
Venice and he was a man he goes now now
you're messy and I'm super clean and he
goes you're gonna stay here and you're
messy I'm gonna ask Rabia ya OCD
cleaning yeah and I had to move out the
next day I was like I got alarm as to
get it I'm I'm messy too though now you
see geniuses are messy you know that
there's not one clean genius in the
world well there you go that's why I'm a
genius take a look at Frank they're
doing push-ups at 50 something Frank
socially I'm telling you I would see
Shrek shrink I'd see Frank at a box and
burn and this is what I was fighting I'd
be in the middle of camp and he's
working harder than me I'm like what's
wrong with he's just that's all strategy
good trauma from his challenge an animal
I'm is such a [ __ ] enemy he's in
there as far as Hollywood goes the
battle Frank as far as work F and like
workouts oh yeah and the only guy who
I'd like a little Frank I have hands
full would be uh Chris Hemsworth yeah
that's because you live but when I first
got Frank invited him though right now I
no way come up from a nap no no Frank
well for sure and I like his enthusiasm
like is that - yeah but when I saw that
man hitting mitts and then Oh big and
strong just Bleen strong quick and then
I'm super athletic a dime peed on me
dine me and I looked I looked at on my
coming around he's done he's like this
is fifth round how many's doing
and I'm talking hard on the [ __ ] so
and he's about is he as big as you not
big as picking the legs or anything but
big uh he's every bit as big as me
that's Chris Hemsworth he's way better
buzz jeez that's the door no he's let's
see him Ron he's six four that's a big
athlete that's a big [ __ ] strong kid
huh oh you know such a I will say yes
our boy Frank were trained with a
Hickson for eight nine years every day
oh no he's got he's pretty good with
jiu-jitsu so if he hasn't had any run on
this time out boxing yeah I know they're
gonna fight just boxing but there's some
of these guys to billing even occur like
it's got Travis Barker I'm talking he
would you would just keep going twenty
rounds or wouldn't break up because of
the drums cuz yeah though built a muscle
memory from the drums of non-stop just
Brian stop that guy Brian stop it Brian
and stop boxing because Brian doesn't
warm up and so Brian got himself a
little you know got some injuries going
it's okay though yeah it happens papa
sure that happens Papa's neck pop his
necks a little stiff right now I'm not
gonna lie to you why cuz I was on a
train or we humpin Nick ish New York and
I've stretched and I turned my head and
and I was like all right
there you go just something came out no
injuries help for your boy no injuries
enough in the arrest I'm glad that
plantar fasciitis plantar fasciitis is
that better
it's completely gone you know why shout
out to all the fans who DME they might
make sure you get custom insoles because
you know I always do kit I'm a frickin
sneaker head so I've so many shoes they
are because your constant changing your
shoes it's tearing up your feet too oh
so like just get one insult put them in
so I went to that wears I have every day
right now these don't manatees dude I
don't up whites
do you like the climbing rope on them
that's all I care about so loes Rock
warm directly to piss you know but due
to have climbing rope on my shoes
because what happens is that their
regulations your shoes go flying off you
got climbing rope and now not only can
you climb in those [ __ ] things but
they double because you can take them
off if you run out of rope but also
they're never coming off your feet in a
street fight because when I kick
somebody in the [ __ ] head sometimes
and I miss them my foot goes from my
shoe goes flying also start with the
off-white also I'm things are going bad
off yourself okay well
Epstein's there well done Lipson sews
the abstains yep now I like that those
are called the Epstein's off-white
Epstein's there's the office of white
UPS teens they're also they're also good
for tying off if you wanna if you want
to shoot up oh right I didn't think
about that
so money now I know it's [ __ ] rock
Monday so I'm gonna go here you can also
tie to the base so you can tie your
piece off at the base and then take a
picture of it well you take a picture of
a big use it hard for quite a while mmm
that's a trick in the gay community I
don't know if you know this also in the
porno community right sure but mostly
the gay community what you want to do is
you want to shave everything down and
you want to put a [ __ ] ring you want to
cinch it around not just the shaft but
around the hole the hole that's right
whole unit what you bring them call you
don't bring it I want to call it a unit
not a unit well no no you you you put
the whole rubber band on the three
pieces in it the three piece set because
it keeps it from looking like a baby
bird look at that baby bird what it'll
do is it'll keep it ten-hut so you get
yourself going a little bit then you tie
off he's always gonna stay a little bit
yes we're saying we want to do is you
want to take you want to you want to
wrap the whole enchilada mm-hmm then
here's the big trick you wear some
sweatpants some of those old school
champion sweatpants right gray well you
don't have underwear on yeah so now you
just you're flopping around inside a new
club that's right now you're just
walking around you're like that guy's
dong is pressing against that cotton
hill yeah now girls would be like gross
but they can't stop staring at it
I am a clown told you the story I had a
guy do that in New York when I'm walking
my dog I had my dog leash and he had a
dick he had as he was doing this with
his I was like your dick is your dick is
your talking me and your dick is at a
three-quarter mast right now you're 3/4
so just writing and you're kind of a big
guy I'm a big guy in your mouth -
salivating no no it's the morning and
I'm immediately this guy's trying to
pick me up and he goes you got kids so
when you say I'm young - I'm probably 25
well I'm gonna ask you right I don't say
no and watch how quickly watch watch
this ready
you got kids no we were involved yeah
well I got oh no I think he was more uh
Latin Oh Oh might have been something
even deeper like Latin but maybe
Bulgaria Romania with dark skin okay
Bulgarian like a long line of Ottoman
blood got some [ __ ] in it that's like
just tricks up his sleeve
yeah with a heavy with a heavy piece and
just a big a big a big heavy body just a
lot of mass a lot of bone and muscle to
move around when he's making a move on
and what do you say did another gay girl
put but you did give him balls in mouth
yeah well no that's that's my that was
digging your balls in while he was in my
acting class and he was a drag queen and
I put no no that was a different thing
and I'll tell you something at the end
of a I might be a coward because I held
my dog tight I had a German clinched up
on that leash oh that was a rough one
cuz that was the same day that my dog
grabbed him a rat later that night he I
went back there cuz I was like if that
guy says something again I'm gonna
[ __ ] tell him I like dude you know you
rethink your thing about the whole day
yeah I don't like being punked cuz I got
a little bit kind of it was big and then
I went back there and my dog grabbed
ahold of a big old rat Chauncey Chauncey
Patti stalk great name
Chauncey is a great dog Corvino fighting
lines she could hang from a rope for 40
minutes she named from her over 40
minutes her whole body she was a [ __ ]
crazy pitbull whatever you think of the
pimples she's made of an alligator I
mean she was I she was now a typical
pitbull correct they're bad for business
she grabbed a hold of a big rat about
the size of chin I mean a giant rat
likes just the biggest thing I got
certainly the size of a small dog Master
Splinter New York rat well fed shook
that [ __ ] in half shook it in half and
a piece of the guts hit me right in the
lower lip second game I I'm still I'm
still cleaning my lips dude I like
seeing a rat
yeah I like when I'm go to New York and
San Francisco see a rat yeah they're
[ __ ] view was that thing saw like a
rat in the wild they're cool to see men
like goddamn you know they're just the
ultimate survivalist they're just making
afraid [ __ ] 24/7 Oh rats you I saw cocky
Roach a at the Pasadena ice house going
to the bathroom for my show this Roach
was [ __ ] the King Kong of roaches big
I thought about taking a picture of Mike
I don't give ice that's bad name
oh you know I did nothing I left that
roach there and I cherry Don I think of
that been a nice pretty young lady that
walked in behind me I'm sure this is one
of those gender-neutral bathrooms no
yeah I'm sure she saw the roach
I think of the Mongols where it gets so
cold in the in these sort of steps up
there and they hunt with Eagles and
traditionally the Mongols there's
nothing there if you look out there it's
just tundra you're on your horse sir and
what you would do is you would live on
well horse blood and their milk but you
would then your wife would catch as many
field mice as possible and sew them all
together well there you go that's those
are the guys your wife would sew as many
of those [ __ ] field mice things
together to create a coat for you now if
you were lucky you wrapped yourself in
Fox or or [ __ ] wolf or whatever you
could catch but what a nightmare
yeah that's not fun to live up there
your Eagles your best or whatever you're
talking about you all goddamn yeah
that's a golden [ __ ] suck nab you a
fox with no problem or whatever you need
what a miserable life yeah
dude did you just change subjects did
you before we go too deep on Mongols did
you see the Golden Globes I didn't watch
it at all
your boy Ricky Gervais is hilarious was
fan did you guys see it Oh Ricky Gervais
spent so hard in the paint where I was
uncomfortable for him but I was laughing
so hard on my couch oh dude he went and
he he basically goes well my my kind of
perspective on being the host of this he
goes it's it's gonna be the last year
I'm ever gonna do it I know I always say
it but this is Lasher I'm never gonna
and he said I want to be like the guy
who's sitting on the couch making fun of
everybody he's like you know that Dinkin
invited the party yes so that that's I
wrote these jokes he goes so hard in the
paint dude I heard like I saw their
makeup people and I was just gonna make
up at school and one of the makeup women
said I get it it was a little
disrespectful oh no so he was so
fantastic you know I end it yeah well a
lot of his jokes like that that he had a
Epstein joke where he goes he said
somebody said Epstein didn't kill
himself
and there goes oh yeah I know he's your
friend I know he's everybody's friend in
here and he goes I don't kill him you do
it like a super light bomb like the joke
would just hit so hard and he go yeah
and there you go oh he goes I don't care
[ __ ] off I don't care I really don't
care it's it was so funny maybe for him
you know he ends it he goes so they
doing the last awarding us all right
we're almost done with his [ __ ] we're
almost done just hang in there were
almost done and then he does he reads
the award and he was right that's it and
then everyone's you know starts clapping
is he good go go to have your drinks to
your parties take all your [ __ ] drugs
[ __ ] off and then walks off it was just
like such a beast
it's great it was so good man's great
was Felicity Huffman there I was invited
to all those parties Frank Grillo
invited me and I just I can't do weather
little I can't do him but they're all so
it's just such a suck me off party yeah
beer I mean you're yeah but day uh it
was interesting too because he was
talking about how oh just how I kick
that off you'd love to friend sidekicks
not because now listen you know you
actors and actors get up here and you
get your award and you you want it you
think your gods and you and you the
bigger cause stuff like this he's like
but what are you talking about he is we
don't need that
get your ward say thanks get offstage
it's not that big a deal he's like your
buddy's fake in here all you were fake
he goes he goes you know how many awards
are up for Apple and their shows he goes
yeah yeah and yet they have kids making
the [ __ ] iPhones using but you don't
say anything about that even let's be
honest if Isis started major streaming
service you'd have your agent calm so
[ __ ] off
inglis let's start the show I love it
you know I love it I love it I love it
it's so true it was so everybody in the
Hollywood is terrified what happens in
Hollywood is you're terrified of pissing
off the wrong person because you don't
know who's gonna give you a job yes and
it's such a collaborative process so you
have to toe the line if the new thing is
gender reassignment surgery if the new
thing is that if you say you're a woman
you better say these are really
important you know my daughter was just
telling me that a Girl Scouts and Boy
Scouts in our UNICEF yeah there's no
more girl it's like it's so ready to win
Steen every was oh he goes hold on he's
not my friend
he you guys created it not me he was I
have nothing to do that's your friend he
just kept going out of miscrit a whole
night [ __ ] it he was the highlight what
do you say about Harvey Weinstein he's
got his trial coming up yeah I forget
what the crazy thing is he's not paying
any money great thing is his insurance
is taking care of all the claims he's
still got a hundred million dollars in
the bank this [ __ ] yeah he's going
today though it's all over two accounts
right yes I'm like yeah even though like
30 women claim it but with the going
globe's I you know what's interesting I
used to work nice to work that stuff I
swear golden the whole Academy Awards
let me see this oh yeah um seen anything
oof I start in Netflix's bird box a
movie where people survive by acting
like they don't see a thing
sort of like working for Harvey
Weinstein what if you did is the best
job he was ever done the other thing is
these these awards being broadcast can't
last too long because no one's watching
them anymore it's kind of like Hollywood
leader yeah it's stuck in each other ah
sir no one's do ratings are like they
are Oh see they're op they've never been
lower so it's like no one's watching
because Hollywood is that they're just
holier than now and when they start
talking people are out yeah it's so good
it's all Ricci to reset the whole tempo
of the whole show cause he goes get your
ward get the [ __ ] off say thanks to your
agent Gil I don't need a whole spiel on
this and let's just get your word get
off nobody gives a [ __ ] yeah and
people get mean you tell they're like oh
one time Zak Cal thanks we were doing
hangover 2 and Zak his friends was Ricky
and I and Jack is the one guy I can
truly say doesn't like celebrity it's
just like he never has been he's always
been the same guy and always just
brutally honest but hilarious and
everything else and I said how are you
liking how are you liking your new fame
because I thought you know I said but
you like he goes but I get to be here in
Thailand nobody knows me so I get to
walk around it's all right he's always
been that way it's not an effect effect
ation and he texts Ricky Gervais he goes
when is he when does Hollywood when does
fame when is the good part of Fame kick
in and Ricky Gervais steps back
on the way down well yeah
what because your boy was on coming the
cars can't copy Seinfeld oh [ __ ]
Sebastian or not enough Sebastian was
but the you were just I'm about from
hangover
Oh Zac Zac was on there and they're
driving down Venice cos he lives kind of
over there and the drum down Venice and
you know the car stopped and people
taking pictures and Ricky owes God man
does this ever get old can you it's just
kind of annoying and Seinfeld tears into
I'm so bad what are you talking about
let's just you signed up for exactly you
would you picture move on makes people
pay your bills exact what you signed up
for exactly well Zack Zack would what
when he was building his house in Venice
and the guy would tell him how much it
was and he goes ah hey look at that he'd
look at all the contractors because how
much maybe it's gonna be another hundred
thousand awesome great so great now so I
gotta do another shitty movie to afford
this I need storm off it was serious and
I was like he's joking that's totally
joking he's lost some weight man yeah
yeah I'll tell you what though eatin
those Golden Globes the the fashion was
awful we've gone like five steps back it
was like really we're in the nineties it
was so we're JLo looked terrible which
is hard to do it was very strange
I am very much I I am starting to
realize how important fashion is and I
never thought I'd say this because I was
always the opposite but now maybe being
around you and stuff when I see somebody
who doesn't have doesn't know how to
dress oh it's
see if they're like a trainer or lover I
go I'm like lazy
well yeah you need to pay more attention
because it does not a different that's
your pop your product this year but it
also is it uh I'm sorry but when people
have fashion sense it makes the world
prettier in its it serves a much bigger
purpose than people realize I think it's
well you know what it is the art its art
its art but also it's also fascist
unexpensive
you can get dope stuff at Target or yeah
ah sir people were talking about
Michelle Williams that's true by the way
you can get you can go to eating your
Zara's isn't so great is it let's tear I
don't know what happened I have no idea
what happened but I'll tell you who was
distracting his [ __ ] I'm gonna be 10%
gay now every time they showed Brad Pitt
it was so distracting cotton bring him
he's he's so goddamn good-looking he's
also been he won that award last night -
so Joaquin Phoenix oh yeah I know I I
told you how much I love you you know
what he made everything everyone made
the odd made the going globe's
eat vegetarian yeah I know it's
plant-based thanks Rocky what is
happening that's him right there
hold on he's here my hair go getting
there
listen you know what I do jealous I both
uses you can grow your hair like that
like you just don't care right it's also
still be still at the top of his game
isn't he well I mean yeah till well
think of Billy one of the final last
movie how old is he 15 some older than
that he's a raging alcoholic for a while
there he smokes smokes a lot yeah vodka
was his choice
56 56 Wow
still looks phenomenal when you have all
your hair like that look at her bite in
the lip forget it 9-piece she's gorgeous
too
she's also 50 he was distracting they
would show me like could be like you
know old old old mature like Jesus
Christ Oh got it oh my got it yeah you
what you won the award
he won for Best Actor uh I forget what
award you won
is that him right there yeah but that's
that's old the him with the long hairs
the new
love is here but well I've ever wanted
to do is grow my hair like that
yeah don't have it just not for you no
and I want to be skinny but day old H
your boy Quentin Tarantino got up there
cuz that you know one spot time in
Hollywood again which is my favorite
movie in a long time I see it it's so
[ __ ] good but he won and it was weird
because I liked him but this was a
little off put away does it because you
know you should I get up and I think
people help me write this and uh you
know collaborated on this writing effort
and getting us movie dungus but I wrote
it myself so there won't be any that
you're sleep
god damn dude he's a genius he's a
genius what's so hard in the paint
yeah you're saying everything that's
worth it is like I wanna seem like a fun
time yeah
jeez I saw him come out of his office on
a lot when he was writing I think it was
inglorious basterds roof is a phenomenal
movie which is a phenomenal it might be
not fine thank you
once upon a time Hollywood's my number
one glorious bastards two or three look
how about Pulp Fiction
the man is dude he's Ingo it's a whole
different thing jangles my dad watch
that my dad was this is fence the
masterpiece looking phenomenal it did
Django for three years and no one
corrected me DJ its integer don't care
don't care solve the D it's okay I think
you have I think you have corrected
almost entirely your speech impediment
yeah when we first met you got a little
bit ODL pediment oh yeah yeah it still
comes out right did you work on it alone
oh yeah you did right yeah yeah
do I speak for a living yeah yeah so I
was like oh well well let's see you did
it quietly oh yeah because I don't
notice it anymore it came out was so
heavy in the beginning i was
super-embarrassed of it yeah i would
make fun of you until I realized it
wasn't your fault
like this was a real speech thing oh
yeah right so I was like oh but then you
what did you do
there's a by witness also install
special you did hmm you sneaky
[ __ ] what am I gonna tell you
dude I don't know it's pretty cool dude
I guess well hey man but it wasn't
public schools that have a speech by you
and I make a lot of
we're talking for a little people need
to hear this because it's in your 30s
you quietly went I have a speech
impediment and you went and got help and
you fixed it and nobody even noticed
until I go hey I've noticed you don't
have a speech and pet him anymore
that's not easy to do now people are
gonna focus on like well I would go back
more but but but what I like about it
you can change and you can apply
yourself and people think that's not
possible
well in time it you I even read a ton of
books to that one time where at dinner
let's go / and we're sitting down with
all those smart people's like oh wow I
can't I can't even if this is jump rope
I can't even get in the game well I
would say that we've been bred and I
would be sitting in in in together on a
plane and because he majored in sports I
would go through some stuff and I would
say to him I would go well I would
television but it was great about as I
would go hey you have to know this now
yeah and you did and you learned but we
lost remote we do long walks off a bit
Ken and we go through like a bunch of
historical history things yeah but it's
so good to hear this for people because
they can [ __ ] in it but it didn't but
all it is I always say I enjoyed it all
this is learning all this is like
putting in a lot more than me about that
stuff whatever but it doesn't mean
anything it just means I just read it it
doesn't if you read the book you'll have
it in your head yeah but you but you
read it and you understand it you can
articulate it in a way that works for me
because when I was in car context do you
have more context and you break it down
for me because when I was in college
they said man I don't care what the [ __ ]
they tell you guys when you go to
college to play a major Division one
sports you're majoring in sports yeah
everything is second yes take it from
your boy man
I'm telling you yeah I'm telling you
that's just what it is so the classes
everything is predicated around you kind
of making sure you pass we stay eligible
so I was like I'm playful long ago the
NFL so education was in a focal point
yeah and then you get out but that was I
was in that lane at the time Last Chance
you and it's probably not just watching
that and I go this is all as a young man
it's all encompassing because it's
everything but yeah but I mean it's even
probably more intense right well cuz I
flunk are heading there [ __ ] up is any
riot
because do you want mouthing rats the
alley cat version of the do you want
knows you guys wake up I got the other
hand in realize until you were I talk to
you is you're up at 6:00 in the morning
running 6 all that'd be nice
it starts at 6 so we got be up at 4:30
that's gotta be a classic horror movie
by 8:00
so you're just running in the cold well
they're trying to break that you're
trying to weed out the guys who don't is
the NFL the same way no it's not no if
you don't do your job you're you're
fired yeah no I'm saying I feel you you
know what early gets the show up do your
job you watch the games
oh yeah you see how how ha palchik
shook graybles hand at the end of that
well you know you mean Grable very brave
over every room yeah but you know why
right he played music yeah you used like
their guys cap team very smart guy so he
out bill check bill chest so crazy with
the taking the delayed penalties and the
punts and all that that's that's of pay
explain that to me because I could see
Belcher corn that's [ __ ] [ __ ]
here I'm gonna [ __ ] [ __ ] but what
was he doing dill I don't understand
what that won't because he'd because so
they were up I think by 3 I figure what
it was but they they want to give Tom
Brady the ball back with the least
amount of time possible so if you take a
penalty it runs off 15 seconds than the
clock the clock continues to run so he's
just draining time so he took the
penalty right so he ran the clock all
the way down took time out took thing
the guy took a penalty so another 15
seconds so he's just trying to run down
time and that guy was offside yeah he's
just run down time it's like it's like a
crinkle in the system Wow it's a page
out of Bill I was about six so mad
because you got our hustle you got our
pump okay in fables you Thracia sinned a
loss oh no you know but I mean have you
ever what's the HP of units the I think
it's like even the Saban Belcher it's
just Omashu biggest egos in the world
talking about football and how great
they are over and I like I like I think
both I like Saban I think both are
fantastic yeah we watch that you like
it's
awful it's just like they're they're
both that cannot it's just they're not
nice Scott no it'd be great if they
should have two of their assistants
talking about them I don't want to see
those two time out how great each other
are it's very strange so it don't but
it's not Nick saying how great bill is
it's Nick Tom bill how Gradius and bill
tell Nick how great he is you know I'm
saying like it's bill saying how he's
the best coach in at the NFL and Nick
saying how he's the best coaching it's
it's so strange man wow I'm like huge
housing Oh Saban has the biggest ego
really and I think that's why Tom Brady
won't be back to New England human bill
checked hate each other what hate each
other
toxic relationship is that true eighty
but they they look what they've done
together
yeah how can you hate each other I did
not know that is that a fact that they
hate each other
I thought any well-known friend oh god
no no how into the owner Kraft and Brady
are best friend there that that's only
reason that's what keeps them that the
and how long is Belichick and Brady been
off for a hot second man Wow I have a
question about Brady at 43 almost now
supplements well yes
I wasn't gonna ask that well yeah you
think you just drink those avocado
shakes but again why why wouldn't you
take starts lon
HGH a no issue with that at all I mean
either because he's 43 and he's great
and the kind of game where his he that
he looks like he's throwing it
everything is right but everyone he's
playing in Sun same [ __ ] here's what I
think is interesting as the season went
on and it's not you can't later at his
feet but they went four and four even
though they were you know so they were
they were they were undefeated they and
ain't no and then they went or informed
that as you get older you it might be a
microsecond but I would imagine you get
a little slower you get a little off the
draw you get you you just you're making
here a second slow yes yeah and that
could be as perfect as he is I think
that might have some do a bluff so he
didn't have any he's not you don't have
anybody signs like this line he's the
only reason they got to know is his
defense really good and they have good
game playing good coaching and they have
a great offense coordinator but it's how
much does he this Brady have to do it
at on a con it runs that [ __ ] he
does 21 years he's been big boy but they
have Adelman you know and he was injured
in in and out they really have anybody
see that's why he's the one of the best
or the best quarterback I don't think
he's the the greatest football player at
time I think he's the best quarterback
of all time I think Jay writes The
Grapes of football player of all time
really look at the numbers no one's ever
gonna cherry rice yeah I know it's never
gonna touch it
he's like Wayne Gretzky in hockey really
yeah you people forget you look at like
oh [ __ ] he was good if you look at that
as far as statistically who's the
greatest professional athlete ever like
competing yeah it's Wayne Gretzky yeah
as far as just like dominating crazy
oh it's also not silt with the physical
tools it's well for I mean he was so
fast
Denis Leary tells a story about he's
with Wayne Gretzky and and I'm trying to
remember the stripe it was on but he
said he said do you think they were at
the half half half court line you know I
don't know how to either this and he
said do you think you could hit the top
goal post you know from here like how
accurate do you think you'd be and Wayne
goes but I can hit five out of ten times
and and Dennis who plays semi-pro hockey
or used to goes excuse me excuse me
cuz he's eccentric ah he has no idea
yeah and he goes I think I can hit five
out of ten and and then I said from here
you could take that puck and hit the top
I'm talking about the top of the
goalpost the bar and he goes yeah well
Wayne did it six out of ten oh yeah
like oh my greatest ever pick up a
[ __ ] yeah and apparently the pause in
the fastest skater didn't have the heart
fastest slot he just was a beast
yeah just understood the game's beast
you know there's Messi this Ronaldo
there's Pele there's Jordan there's
Barry Sanders Joe Montana Jerry Rice
Wayne gothy they pick one swing good
Wangler look at the records like oh you
know it's a flower Dickens ever get what
you did what yeah
any key they got what the guys are doing
now like point that up they're not even
close no he's so [ __ ] good yeah
that's so sick in it crazy yeah I mean
he's what he's six feet or something and
and create and just create us
show Vedad yes who is brands are looking
ezel ain't seen ain't seen his daughter
we ain't seen it so he's 6 you'll see
see how she's dating a golfer of course
what see if I just say dumb things
sometimes well she's getting a little
bit of trouble what happened
uh she was like he got mad at she was
posting and risky [ __ ]
oh she's she'd be my one healthy box am
i right well know that she married a guy
we do know she married a guy who looks a
lot like her dad right hmm a little bit
some angles uh maybe the same knows
she's she's a beauty yeah she's a dime a
dime you know I mean Gretzky pregnant
our boy but would your boy Ryan Bader
married a very wealthy smoke show she
comes from a long line of like some
she's got a lot of money Bader did yep
how do you know I know people who know
him and they were talking about how
awesome his wife is but also how wealthy
her family is and interesting yeah yeah
Bader is a super time piece too he's a
stud by the way good correct lookin damn
look at them look at that is that
Beyonce next - no that's Sierra you
racist [ __ ] it's hard to see you say not
at all who is Sierra how the sorry she's
beating that football player no she's
married with a kid to Russell Wilson
said that starting quarterback Seattle
Seahawks
Russell Wilson did pretty well how about
your boy Marshawn Lynch making a
comeback I know right yeah doing the
damn boy Tariq worked out ready sessions
yeah yeah my boy tarde got Marshawn
Lynch ready yep I'm so fine dad yes so
Sierra where's was made I'm just gonna
educate you old ass mmm hey boomer check
it so Sierra I gosh she good-looking oh
my god have you seen in person what the
[ __ ] is going and she could sing and she
can dance what it hold on
that's ridiculous never seen before huh
no she she was made to a guy named
future a rapper
she was just with him I know that a
critical future is that a kid know whose
baby future is also future and now
Russell Wilson has a rule in training
camp you know that played music during
practice you can't play any future songs
he [ __ ]
you can't they don't play future songs
[ __ ] you future future create some hits
though ISM is Russell wasn't such a
baller he's so [ __ ] good he's so good
he'd be my MVP again reeling with much
yeah or if you had to put your money on
it right now Lamar Jackson all day who
wins you know heard of them that's what
it well I I know I have how about how
about a Henry the running back for ten
Titans man oh my god you know if you
wanted yes oh I was watching the
highlights what are you such a beast so
big and so fast it's so ridiculous oh my
god
mm-hmm oh yes here this body the [ __ ] oh
well look at her face
Russell Wilson looks miserable there
he's an athlete
Oh athlete eat that [ __ ] up man yeah
yeah he looks bloated this [ __ ] oh
that's happy there kid you can that's
futures kid they have the weigh-in
Versace
that's futures kids unless you need ads
named like he looks miserable there
again yeah
she's tall by the way how tall is
Russell he's not tall six money
he's what gave all the small guys
besides drew brees hope yeah he's all
that thicker than breeze does neither
looks like he's a thick fella it's
thicker 511 now yeah he's small that's
what cuz being under six foot was a big
deal oh that's why I didn't get drafted
first like carson wentz all those guys
are so tall six six cars wants nowhere
near as good as him Tyler Murray 510
drew brees six-foot you don't want a
real big quarterback well it's too long
to release the football huh but a lot of
really good ones Hart all new blood show
all those guys were all talk let's hold
on yeah no yes 1993 yeah no I know yeah
yeah I'll get back though all right cool
no but listen but they've always been
tall like Randall Cunningham was really
totally here we go person ya know do you
see Brandon yeah no those are only
references at article yep I got you I'm
Annie Peyton Manning big big guys yeah
Tom Brady old old old old old but but so
old also things have change changing a
little was shortened smaller ones yes
cuz to be people are like oh you have to
be big and tall play quarterback
and then drew Bree said hold my [ __ ]
right hold my birthmark
yeah and [ __ ] it started playing ball oh
my birthmark hold my first part now so
he's he's six foot maybe that's being
generous I'm a home my home is six three
we got our boy from who plays for Green
Bay in Roger Roger six three but again
the Drew Brees Drew Brees calimary
Russell Wilson Lamar Jackson the Marcus
is not tall it's not huge
no he's small that's why Marge acted I'm
gonna say he's at least six to them I
would say six one that's why they're
worried they taking so many hits cuz I'm
a big dude what's his longevity yeah six
dear
so I mean six months yeah Michael Vick
six foot you know yeah yeah the age of
the real don't say I'm still gonna say
the average is six three maybe no I'd
say average yeah that's probably three
six two yeah but what not six six not
six seven no my point is is you you can
be small be a superb all right cuz I
thought it was going to house so real to
me Russell should be MVP really yeah
plays in the toughest division there's
no you know doesn't have a ton of help
the the you know why didn't you ever
play linebacker I don't know man I don't
give a [ __ ] play how about you suck this
oh you suck my dick why did you say why
don't you play defense i apiece so hard
why don't you play quarterback hut hut
hike hike hike
hey let me pee real quick I got a pistol
hissing quietly secure your hips hey why
don't you play hockey because I didn't
want to ice hockey so expensive by the
way that's why a lot of kids don't play
it really it's so expensive
hi the skate ice time the old equipment
it's so expensive I was like kids don't
play anyone unless you're in Canada your
dad's right this episode of final kid
comes from manscaped who was the best in
the world in men's below the belt
grooming manscaped offers precision
engineered tools for your family jewels
maybe they get one for Christmas so get
yourself the gift that keeps on giving
you don't have to wait for someone else
to give you
a gift of trimming your nuts it's 2020
and you know what that means new year
new me new fresh nice cut up balls all
right listen up guys hairy butchers our
show last year if you're going to pick
any New Year's resolution this year let
it be you take care of your junk
manscaped is making it easy with their
grooming products
that's why manscaped has redesigned the
electric trimmer there's a lot more 2.0
skin-safe technology so this trimmer
won't Knick or snag you'll nuts
manscaping accents are finally a thing
of the past
alright manscape also has the crop
preserver at an anti chafing ball
deodorant moisturizer you ready put
urine on your armpits why not put it on
your nuts you 20% off and free shipping
with the code fighter at manscape comm
start the new year off right by using
the best tools for the job
your nuts will thank you your balls
thank you key points off and free
shipping with the code fighter at
manscape comm that's 20% off and free
shipping at manscape comm use the code
either hey everybody do you have student
loans refinancing them with earnest
could save you money on lower your
monthly payment it only takes two
minutes to check your rate online little
financial relief goes a long way student
loan refinancing with earnest can help
you pick a monthly payment that fits
your budget so you can breathe easy
relax don't be so stressed out alright
if you're still paying the same rate
your pain when you graduated are all man
odds are you could reduce your monthly
payment and save big even even if you
refinance before forget about it with
today's low rate environment most people
can save by refinancing again earnest is
the easiest way to refinance your
student loans saving you time and money
checking your new rate is so easy it's
fast to start complete a few questions
online only takes about two minutes you
get a personalized rate estimate all
without affecting your credit score if
you qualify earnest offers loan terms
and no fees you can combine private
federal loans imagine having one single
monthly payment with one low rate what's
already refinance no problemo you can
still be eligible to lower your rate
right now start saving today you guys
get a hunter dollars cash bonus when you
refinance a student loan at earnest calm
/ fighter
$100 cash bonus when you refinance a
student loan at earnest calm / fighter
go to earnest calm / fighter today terms
conditions play earnest calm / fighter
how's that muffin I sit like that it's
[ __ ] delicious why why because my
neck and my back tends to be if he had
to lunch tup tends to be iffy at times
now you know I was a little sick but
daddy has his secret weapon oregano oil
and elderberry syrup okay okay now I
know that your look mmm
but daddy keeps his viral load down when
he's sick with those two things and
sleep and water and daddy
dude it's ready to rock with his [ __ ]
out on Monday okay okay no we're going
now
now Johnny using all day ahead of me I
gotta get to set and I got to do a bunch
of exercise okay I'm physically running
around today are you yeah do I want to
do that no if he neck a little tweaky
back and you're doing in Teaneck shorts
do it in my shorts you guys stop when
you guys rap got eight more weeks buddy
two months nine with a long long in two
months then we get back to some other
stuff we're gonna do yeah oh dude how
about I got my kid he won't pipe down
cuz he every morning I worked out on my
Palatine bike and he wants his own so he
has like this Batman bike but it's not a
stationary bike so he rides it in my
driveway like in circles like a crazy
man
you just keep I put music on from just
rides it while I'm on my peloton he
worked out every morning and so he keeps
harassing me to get a peloton I was like
I've been looking looking then finally I
found when I posted on my Instagram Jim
finally found one people keep asking who
makes that I posted on my story
fisher-price makes a kid's stationary
bike so but it connects via bluetooth -
no it's not my storage and it's on my on
the wall
kid riding a bike for god sakes yeah
sorry so wants to meet you he wants you
could his hair so I'm right next to him
so he rides when I ride but you said so
it connects via bluetooth to iPad screen
so it's like a peloton and then the the
thing is he's a little character and
they have trails and so he's going and
staying with the trails while I'm going
oh it's cool ha that's so we were down
there for two hours working out really
Oh - oh he's aldis down for that it's
all he cares them as called the great
relaxer not this one man he's like
what's that you could go ahead I'm gonna
put my hands behind my head and she had
a relax and watch something uh yeah I
mean he's a smart kid
oh he's not well I'll walk in the house
and he's ready oh yeah I walk in the
house he's like this come on papa I'm
like dude that's so key those cute oh my
god but it's good because I'm working
out two three times a day now because
you only go on if I'm on so they
probably get on the bike pedaling you
laugh or you worked out he's that go
popping all right let's do UI so you get
you get yourself palate sense at it or
do you do some weight lifting stuff I
get some nice come on bro you see the
[ __ ] see some stuff set up
you got some fake grass down there too I
like that I like turf oh yeah you got
that in the garage yeah bro come on
that's what I'm gonna do the same
[ __ ] thing I had that too in my house
I like it a lot what a little fake turf
doing that oh yeah
I'll [ __ ] you know cuz I was gonna do
poured cement but maybe I'll lay some
fake turf down it's way better way
better
nice better looks cool yeah I'm all over
it open up the garage oh that's the
tunes
yeah YouTube playing the TV all over the
teams I'm so psyched you just gave me a
great idea
oh thanks broad on what
Rondon oh all right man
yeah but peloton should make one for
kids man like it more cuz this one even
you know he's paddling is going but it's
he can't get into yeah yeah kids are
young he likes that one doubts your
son's gonna be a beast
yeah is espresso
and he's got your hair these little
pants oh there it is oh my god yeah but
everyone gives us its fisher-price I got
fans on for God's sakes let's do some
veteran events kids current events hey
by the way Nashville really quickly
they're thinking about adding a third
show on Saturday I don't you're only
doing two shows two shows cuz I'm
working so gonna fly in Friday - chefs
Friday - so Saturday then I go back oh
you don't do in Thursday then I got a
shoot again I'm shooting on thirst oh I
understand I had to take Friday off very
very lucky to be able to do so yeah so
that's what it is your boys in this 20
tickets left Wilber Saturday Oh
beautiful that's so that [ __ ] out there
you go Friday
Foxwoods Connecticut good stuff - I've
been a Foxwoods sure having the rice and
raves about it huh you don't like Cassie
see I like casinos just Borgata I was on
the best of venues I've ever done yeah
more gatos dope
sure was Foxwoods no huh Fox was flying
into Boston and driving
hey go you're flying in the Boston going
down to Bob Foxwoods good yeah the best
that way then I want you to do is I'm
gonna do a show when you're getting your
car and drive back to Boston
the Thunder God and do that that's the
plan dude oh that's nice though yeah
you're gonna have fun the theater there
uh Wilbur nothing better Wilbur I got
Cleveland hilarities oh yes Nick donar
yep I'm excited you're back while since
I've been as a give me a bat yet no get
a sellout
I will it's been a while though and so
Cleveland and that's one of the best
clubs in the nation yeah so fun you know
now they don't you know how clubs do
like the check drop like when you're
about to close your set yeah
they don't they wait till the show's
over and one of the only clubs that do
that so doesn't [ __ ] up the comedian's
that oh wow they wait pretty cool really
cool you know it's distract them on this
check drop yeah that's very something I
love that hilarious also has the best
food yeah I'd say because there's a
steakhouse above Nick's a class act
well the best you want to talk about a
man who knows how to keep himself
together
I know physically funny - I mean it's
humble
yeah he's a man he gave me a bat for
selling out and I it's in my basement
framed that's pretty cool
Greg I can't wait for that club that's
gonna be fun I'm jealous man it's an old
school it's sounding great area dude
yeah there's great hotels around that
great hotels in it too great food
where'd you stay cuz I need to know the
objects any of the hotel good cuz I was
saying this hotel and there's also a
great coffee below so it's perfect last
time I was there I was trying new stuff
that's out of there I had a brand-new
set was a hit or miss and dove and Iraq
co-headlining in dub was boiling doesn't
washing yeah well how long will that six
years ago really leathe least you and
dove together torn oh dude eight years
ago see I'm done since I've met you
correct walked nine years and probably
some crazy yeah it was a long time all
right what do we got okay so this woman
is currently my favorite person her name
is Kailyn morg she's a 20 year old nude
model who the other day on across the
board on social media people were
tweeting posting photos of Australia
because it's currently on fire yeah this
woman she saw all those posts she
decided to donate but she felt like
Australia wasn't getting enough coverage
here in the US and so she made made it a
point to tweet out that for every single
person who donates at least $10 to a
foundation that will help Australia she
will send you a nude photo
she's a frog and so yeah again right now
she ended up raising half a million
dollars in a couple of days and
Instagram ended up deactivating her
account saying that she broke some sort
of rule even though she posted it onto
Twitter she's so hot
she's saving the world with our nudes
she's she's outstanding most girls are
send them for that every face we get her
changing the world changing the world
look at that box there any way we can
get some some nudes whatever because I
want to see what's cool I want to make
sure we are on Nate
she made 100 and she's donating a
hundred K in one day yeah I'm not trying
to I don't I just was wondering if
there's any way I baby she got a census
she said hide you got the yeah
deactivated my family disowned me oh wow
well and the guy I like won't talk to me
all because of the tweet but [ __ ] it
saved Australia good for you honey
yeah dude oh yeah she's sending photos
like that but also let's figure it out
let Brian and pop over here big pop call
me let me help it they've got like
Popeye little mean ranks and little
ranks well let the ring some big Papa
figure it out yeah that's all do you
need a trip to LA you got everything you
need here you got experience
yeah she's sending photos like this
she's she's delicious and that's
probably the best angle of all time and
he said I agree she's saving Australia
one [ __ ] aspic at a time wow she's a
nude model so there must be some nice
really uh no she is American but she she
has a big heart you know no she's a
great fantastic yeah she's doing the
Lord's work
yeah the Lord actually God's work right
there God created it you got a problem
with that ass and that smiley face I
have no problem with anything going on
here because I celebrate everything I'm
enjoying my muffin right now but that's
not hard one day and rocked up and she's
a great addition I'm rocked up bebop and
rocksteady yeah you got a dick boy give
that thing some air and they're digging
my balls look at that just good
my mama what else he got okay so a fake
psychic from Massachusetts was recently
arrested because she convinced one of
her customers that her ten-year-old
daughter was possessed by a demon and
she ended up racking up a bunch of like
fake charges saying I can get this demon
out of your child if you pay me for this
ceremony and this and that she ended up
getting 70 grand out of this woman right
uh also uh also an episode of True Blood
this happened in True Blood but isn't
the woman who spent 70 grand liable yeah
I agree
incredible [ __ ] so you shot a Ponzi
scheme that's not you bro should you be
fine for being dominated
should you just lose the money for being
a [ __ ] yeah you shouldn't have that
money
who got how did she have 70 grand to
giveaway when you're when she's that
dumb I feel like people who go to
psychics are generally rich or like have
some money to go
and also not sometimes also Dom I know a
few people were broke and went when I
was a kid psychic okay
go [ __ ] yourself haha thank you oh
you're gonna Cleavon that remind me have
you ever heard that story I don't remind
me of it I was just on 20/20 the dude
who kidnapped three girls for nine years
or in shackled him in his basement I
raped him and they had kids and an
addict the hell is in the basement okay
and they had kids and all [ __ ] and he
was a bus driver and then finally in the
the the lady he was raping had a baby
yeah in the house has the kid the the
mom creates she's shackled creates like
a like a preschool basically in the room
so the kids like loving her dad has no
idea like why he shackled up momma and
stuff and then he on chapel's her
because the kid kept was likewise mom
always tied up so he on shackles are
right
she always locked the door when he left
right they were always there nine years
missing nine [ __ ] years been raped
tortured all that [ __ ] nine years she
leaves to go get some leaves the door
locked
that was Dadar comes upstairs opens the
door goes mama Papa left where did he go
she's like
excuse me Seiko he laughs and she's like
how did you get in her go back now she
was how did you get in she goes your
doors unlocked
she runs outside alerts somebody walking
by the police come and she goes I'm I
forget named Amanda whatever Amanda
berry I was the one who kidnapped nine
years ago and the cop doesn't really
believe it but they send people over
there and they saved the other three
girls so he gets prison he it's to life
commit suicide among into it commit so
so good for him real piece of [ __ ] of
course I hope he'd [ __ ] about you
though rots piece of [ __ ] who's this guy
some bad people huh dude a horrible
person look at these guys who kidnap
dude he kid he kidnap one girl she was
this is the most heartbreaking thing so
you see the girl in the middle you see
the girl in the middle yeah she would
rent ran away from home to sexual abuse
and his shitty parents so ran right into
him
so well yeah but nine years go by being
tortured raped all that stuff and they
get to the hospital and there's a whole
huge announcement you know it's a huge
touring Cleveland aurelion nationwide
huge touring Cleveland Amanda Berry rest
the kids rescued nine years after they
are alive they're at this hospital so
all the the other two girls parents
rushed on not one person came to see her
that was the most heartbreaking thing so
she's waiting at the hospital the
parents like now we're good how he think
help terrible people better now she's
married though she's good
but because she he would rape her so
many times she kept a journal this it
was so [ __ ] up she kept a journal and
she writing every day he would allow him
to do that writing like right stuff and
wrong [ __ ] and every time she would rape
she got raped she would start at the top
of her journal they're going through the
journals some have five stars on them
some have six stars on so I have four
stars on him
she had like 15 miscarriages cuz she get
pregnant and you'd like kick in the
stomach
I just you'd fall asleep and wake up and
he jump on her stomach
what oh yeah or kick her downstairs or
starve er so she'd lose the baby so now
she's older and she's married she wants
to have kids you can't she was like
that's way the worst thing he did to me
she wants to have a tough person though
that little girl's [ __ ] tough she was
14 when she got get mad no she was a
little older
she was only like 17 or something 16
horrible what a so terrible man what a
piece of [ __ ] but the bomber thing is
they allow them to commit suicide like
that [ __ ] [ __ ] Wow put him in
gen-pop see what they do yeah I know but
you know he's dead yeah he's dead but
still evil PC shut the house of horrors
yeah
Wow probably give me a movie someday huh
want to put a tracking device on my
children yeah under their skin yeah it's
tough yeah I think that's what you say I
think that's worth doing Jack a vice
yeah I don't know what you do man I
don't know what you do oh just a
grinding Cleveland hilarity see me in
Nashville this week House of comedy
House of or Zanies what else yet hmm
okay so a bad baby she's the girl who
was on dr. Phil who went viral cuz she
said cash me aside how about that oh
yeah she puts Adrien Broner on blast you
know he basically DM her saying text me
crazy girl and she posted that up along
with a video of a con song locked up and
she says stop trying to holler at me I'm
only 16 and he goes out and he
apologizes saying that he didn't know
that she was 16 she's still 16 well she
was popping off when she was like 14 so
yes 16 right now he's 16 and she's sick
so SCA she's 16 six she was good well
and I think that's the same reaction
Adrien Broner had one shot no Broner he
went out and he apologizing that he
didn't know that she was 16 and that he
blames Instagram for not putting
people's ages on that come on and I was
like well you know she looks every bit
of what 25 I at least 22 I would not
know she's 16 and damn she's sixteen
sixteen
you know seobeom was in her yeah he was
like though what is she doing man right
girl
ROG he is a rapper yeah she had cyborgs
in one of her music videos I think
she got a fight with another oh yeah
whoa Vicki another like straight-up
fight I don't know why I watched that
because that's frightening yeah she's uh
pretending to be black but she's white
seems like she's pretending to be
something well she's kind of
controversial because people said that
she is training black well she and that
the way that she speaks she's trying to
speak like a black person but she came
out and said that she's ghetto and that
she's not trying to pretend to be black
but she's only going on our videos where
she's talking to she's making her skin
browner and all that hold up why is
Rogan on a page real quick yes you
probably and she becomes a
multi-millionaire she's huge she's
famous
she sells makeup she's got a [ __ ]
giant billboard on sunset I'm gonna be
honest with you I listened to her rap
album and it is good there you go she's
hypnotizing Tony and she becomes a
multi-millionaire she put your right
Thank You Richie uh you're right thank
you I appreciate it I still think your
movie sucked though knocked up was trash
watch she thinks he's done uptown I
don't know she's just joking most likely
drawing no nope I don't think so
knocked up that's like Seth Rogen oh she
thinks it's Seth Rogen she's just oh no
she's 16 you're giving too much credit
check trust me
Wow interesting yeah wow that took a
wait curveball [ __ ] I thought Instagram
did she 16 though a lot of her thing
just comes from to create this shell
because her family's so [ __ ] up she
actually got some tits
you know she's 16 can you do that well
do what get implants yeah yeah you just
need to get parents permission
those are real there's no reason why she
wouldn't have real tits at 16 like that
but she's got it's interesting because
she what is your nationality no I think
she's
she has learned Italian last name yes
she's a time bad baby
what is that that's that's not sure
really was like Danielle's an
african-american no click on it lets her
talk she's not talking to either I think
you might have to go I love that she's
something let's try this one
never mind it's all just songs she's had
some work done for sure Oh pink so it's
very pretty she's pretty right very
pretty
the other thing is to you know town wise
I don't know but she made a little out
of a lot right she's making millions no
it's cool there's like yeah well I
wonder if she goes that night we got she
looks like she's pissed
oh yeah she's a man she's not happy
whatever she's making a lot of money to
certain to certain music videos get a
lot of views hell yeah
well as a career for God's sake yeah she
might just be a really talented gal that
had designs on being a rapper like
something she might have just like
sometimes it's like oh you're actually
good at hunting original that million
views seven noises scrubbers she might
be if you're if you're she might just be
an artist and a young artist doesn't
know do with her engine yet that's all
her manager actually used to live at the
apartment I used to work at and from
what he told me she was trying to get
famous off of like the dr. Phil kind of
reality show oh yeah she uh no she went
on the kettle [ __ ] relationship with
her mom and then the crowd started going
at her yeah and you know I can't write
this but she she was 13 I think she was
alright catch me outside then that went
viral and then she decided to somebody
but the interesting thing is that she
got herself on dr. Phil she has a family
she was rebelling against she might be
this kind of like girl who was like this
is not where I want to be my family
doesn't know what the [ __ ] they're doing
mm-hm
and she was already intelligent enough
or at least hungry enough ambitious
enough or different enough to want
something more she just didn't know what
it was absolutely you know what I mean
there's just something about her and if
her I rap album is good and she's still
doing it something's working and she
looks great
yeah there's if there's a discipline
there too
she looks for really good she's not
spinning out of control she has walls
bit up built up because she had to
that's what I'm saying this is all a
shell for her bad Barbie look at her I
was it Barbie or baby
I think it's baby whatever it is but
yeah everything she does is super
calculated someone's paying attention
[ __ ] as tornadoes that's what I said an
opal she's a kid some [ __ ] gonna fly
over us she's Italian but she's every
bit of black she's got that urban
African I'm
American like whatever it is whatever if
that's what you grow up around like it's
it's like if you grow up or an English
people without accent you people that's
right up there lingo and that's like if
that's all you know right everyone's
that go accurate wrong but if that's all
if she's encompassed in that world and
it just means that race race is like a
construct in its own way - in a way like
it you can see this it's like we are
living in a time where you can be
anybody you want everyone know everyone
says oh she's acting black or you know
Gatos up she's have you ever got your
pop culture culture head cuz now I want
to say pop culture but have you ever
seen like this is just music culture
though you know but she's acting like
hood but he ever got a white hood like
it the trailer parts they're very sim
there's guys in the south where act
[ __ ] ya know hood well Thomas soul
doesn't think about it's a book called
white black rednecks and white liberals
and if you look at like ghetto black
culture it came at was very heavily
influenced by the North England redneck
culture that that they were sort of
subjugated by as slaves but my thing is
with her to look so she has her makeup
line she has her music she has the
fashion of a clothing she has a hundred
thirty five million views on her last
music video so as much hate as she's
getting some someone's paying attention
someone's buying her product Sean this
morning a huge fan base with a like it
takes a lot of look she's dancing she's
performing you know this a she's
performing she's I mean whatever the
case she got herself up there with her
music her looks and her dancing anybody
else want to try that guy mm-hmm she's
it takes in no energy videos for me and
you have to be reliable there's reason
you like I like Kodak blacks working
with her 27 million views look at how
she's
that's poison front of a camera five
hundred fifty five thousand likes 31
dislikes you know much just 60 notes
making off her YouTube and music yeah
much how much was making
dude half a mil
but more than that you got in their
makeup in her Turin just make him one
that for sure yeah so she's making tens
of millions of dollars a year at least a
million dollars a month at least killing
the game what can you do
she's more talented than Takashi six
nine oh I was trying to be a gangster
absolutely and we got way too deep into
it and it was like a [ __ ] you know this
girl this uh is it Taj Sultana Taj
Sultana I think her name she's so
[ __ ] awesome she's non-binary she's
Australian no no she's so cool she's
been playing forever yeah this this this
bringin her videos she's so good have
you seen her
jungle what's it called in the jungle
she plays all the her own instruments
she's a one-man band one gal band one
person band one-man band yeah she's like
impaired she's she's so [ __ ] good on
the three years ago
yeah jungle like just watch watch her do
this [ __ ] we can't play here this uncha
now can kill the guitar kills a guitar
she does what plague go forward so you
can hear her voice dang she's amazing
have you heard tones and I know but I
love her hey I gotta go
man's work you go back to see ya man you
come see me at Nashville January 1011
this weekend Friday Saturday that I'm
Cleveland January 30th 31st
Feb 1 and then I got West Palm Beach Oh
and that would be Valentine's Day
Brennan you're in I'm in San Jose well
Valentine's Day oh nice you're at the
Wilbur it's we met Wilbur Saturday
Foxwoods Connecticut's Casino on Friday
that's this Friday Saturday bosses on
Saturday next week in San Jose that is a
Friday Saturday Sunday Oh Friday
Saturday Sunday and then after that I am
in Charlotte Charlotte Omni Zone
Charlotte off Charlotte last my way my
call all right please and then so
Charlotte and then
week in Columbus Ohio funnybone Columbus
Ohio that those dates just got announced
oh my am i right yeah I'm right all
right Charlotte January 23rd 25th
Columbus January 31st February 1 San
Jose January 17th to the 19th and then
yeah Ontario just want to say off to
CPAC a calm for Brian and myself be get
your eyes set but on short shorts boy
good boy
dude we're doing fighting pain Thursday
yeah forgot I'm psyched me too
later writes this five kid route